The most important thing is to know what is important to your boss, and what his or her priorities are.
If your boss is a numbers person, provide results in a statistical way...
...and be sure to know which numbers are important.
If he or she is a customer-oriented person, highlight the benefits to customers in your work.
Use the communication tool that your boss prefers, i.e. email, voicemail, in person, etc.
Some people like a lot of information, others less.
Paying attention to how your boss communicates with you should give you some good tips.
Whenever you did something that had an impact on the department, mention it!
Take responsibility for work that needs doing before your boss notices and asks you to do it.
He or she will appreciate your foresight and competence.
Be sure to be a good listener and ask unexpected questions.
You will be a true asset, and your boss will think you are a good influence on the team and his own work.